on dort à soir et après fillon nous nous
sommes l'honneur de la france
mais croyez moi on va la gagner cette
guerre un humour toujours aussi absurde
le palmashow conserve sa marque de
fabrique le duo formé par grégoire ludig
et david marsais sort son premier film
la folle histoire de max et leon
l'histoire de deux amis d'enfance qui
tente d'échapper à la seconde guerre
mondiale une comédie d'aventuré inspiré
par les grands films du genre la comédie
d aventure c'est un style qui n'existe
plus beaucoup dans le cinéma français
dont il est très fan de la grande
vadrouille la 7ème compagnie papy fait
de la résistance
donc on a eu envie de s'inscrire
humblement en fait dans cette lignée
tout en faisant peut-être des parallèles
un peu plus moderne avec la société a en
plus la seconde guerre mondiale c'est
une période qui est très
cinématographique
donc nous qui permettait sur un film
d'époque en costumes
originaire des yvelines les deux
compères sont retournés à la maison le
21 octobre dernier lors de l'avant
première organisée par l'ugc skywest les
humoristes ont expliqué leur désir
d'aborder cette thématique est
différemment et cynisme avec sur la
seconde guerre mondiale avec les
méchants nazis avec hitler etc
on le sait ça y'a aucun problème est
justement on n'avait pas envie de nous
de traiter de ça on avait plutôt envie
de traiter du kung fu de l'intérieur
c'est à dire comment les français
réagissent et entre eux donc c'est un
tout qui est assez franchouillard c'est
surtout un film qui a qu'à du recul sur
cette période
connu pour ses sketchs sur internet puis
sur direct 8 en dix ans le tandem a
construit sa réputation sur la parodie
et sur des personnages extravagants pour
leur film les deux amis ont voulu se
détacher de cette écriture écrire un
sketch écrire un film c'est vraiment
différent à ce qu'elles sont les cris en
une journée à peu près et le film on l'a
mis deux ans et demi à l'écrire voulait
pas prendre les gens pour des cons
coixet et de que les gens viennent et
disent ah tiens ça c'est exactement ce
qu'ils font la télé en fait il fallait
qu'on
il fallait qu'on passe à l'étape son
métrage qu'on n'avait pas envie de
prendre les personnages qu'on fait dans
les sketchs et les tirer et faire une
heure et demie de gaspard et balthazar
et qui n'est pas ce que ça marche en ce
cas justement les personnages dans les
sketches dont les écrits il faut très
vite l'on sache pourquoi ils sont drôles
donc on le retrouve des caractéristiques
assez assez poussée trop même
il faut leur donner ce côté marrant tout
de suite or là dans le film on a
vraiment pris le temps reste est
appréciable de faire évoluer les
personnages pour leur tournage ils ont
traversé la france et la belgique ont
endossé les costumes de résistants ou de
ss2 véritable caméléon ou leur folle
histoire sortira en salles le 1er
novembre